you ready to get fronting re is this car
this is getting crush pool pool pool
pool pool booming 808 beats catchy group
vocal hooks quick hi-hat rolls and a
triplet rap flow these are some of the
defining features of trap music today's
most popular let's go back 25 years to a
group that pioneered the sound before
the word trapped was even used to
describe music
and our episode on trap music we covered
how the genre was formed in Atlanta by
artist Gucci Mane Ti and Young Jeezy to
become the phenomenon that it is today
but now we want to focus on a group that
came before them and laid the groundwork
for track three 6 mafia what we caught
trap music today is really a blend of
several hip hop genres from all over the
south one of the most influential is
crumb a slower more severe style of rap
music that we've Club in party culture
with gang life and although three 6
mafia are responsible for popularizing
the genre the sound can be traced to
another Memphis artist DJ Spanish Fly
I'm not familiar with any of these
artists ok it's been eye-opening not
even like the newer stuff like Soulja
Boy you know well no no not at all for
me as a musician hearing the different
elements of what goes into music like
rock music it makes me kind of think
about oh these specific musical elements
really allow the musicians to tap into
these types of emotions and I think
that's fascinating sonically konk
emphasizes aggression and tension via
minor chords slow tempos distorted bass
contrasting rhythms and often abrasive
Tambor's you can hear this in the video
game like beats of Tommy Wright the
third
[Music]
early crank producers often use these
homemade sounds in place of the standard
hip-hop building blocks of funk and soul
samples used by east coast rappers this
sound was paralleled by the growing
popularity of a dancing style called
gangsta walking which moved between
elegant fluid footwork to dramatic pop
locking and stomps in the early 90s
three 6 mafia emerged from emphasis DIY
mix tech community where local artists
would create and sell cassette tapes
that mix their own music with popular
hip-hop while in high school
DJ Paul and Lord infamous formed the
serial killers and put out regular
mixtapes adding their own production and
layers of triplet rap flows to hip-hop
hits these self-produced hybrid
playlists allowed up-and-coming and
entrepreneurial rappers to promote their
music and make money in the process in
the early 90s the duo began working with
other local artists after adding
producer Juicy J rappers gangsta boo
crunchy black and coupes to join and the
group took on the name three 6 mafia as
crunk became more popular in Memphis
during the early 90s the city's black
community was under siege from the crack
epidemic increasing street violence made
it one of America's most dangerous
cities the hard-hitting sound of three 6
mafia echoed the rawness of these issues
the vocal chants Lord infamous triplet
flows and DJ pause menacing minimalist
beats created the model for early crunk
and the sonic template for Travis
[Music]
like it's ultra violent lyrics three 6
mafia emphasized tension sonically in
the music in their 1997 track profit
Posse the sample of the triggerman beat
is in a different key than the
synthesizer melodies creating a poly
tonal harmony the simultaneous use of
two or more keys in a musical
composition of course it's not a new
trick this technique has been used by
many composers including myself to
create tension between what most
listeners expect a standard progression
that resolves to a stable tonic and what
we get distance so this is an example of
poly harmony we have one key another one
F major combine them something like this
[Music]
three 6 mafia's beats lay down the
groundwork for today's trap music their
songs amp up the listener through heavy
bass lines synthesizer melodies minor
key harmonies that create a foreboding
mood and of course the role in 808 we
can even hear how these intermittent
hi-hat rolls would turn into the
rapid-fire hi-hat sound of Atlanta trap
these are not the only way 3 6 is
inspired today's rap music today we call
the double-time triplet flow the migos
flow I give it some rice a total go
shopping and spend it all at the pop-up
but it's actually Lord infamous of three
6 mafia who is credited as the
originator well you wanted the witnesses
be very quiet yes double inches while
this claim cause beef between three 6
mafia in Cleveland's bone
thugs-n-harmony the Memphis flow was
declamatory in-your-face regular and
meter and more staccato than bone thugs
is harmonic and more rhythmically
complex group rapping here's the trap
superstar 2 Chainz stating this claim in
his song trap back in the early 2000s
crunk rocks with charts songs by Atlanta
based artists like Lil Jon & the east
side Boyz get low and the Ying Yang
Twins saltshaker had crossover
popularity both in dance clubs and in
the strip club scene variations of crunk
began emerging on hip-hop radio life
snapping some we're doing this time the
sounds of crunk snap trap and other
hip-hop genres from the south all merged
into them today we just called it our
trap but it's really a mix of New
Orleans bounce houston chopping screwed
Miami bass and Memphis crunk it's hard
to point the origin to one city or
artist but three 6 mafia were
instrumental in creating the sound of
modern hip-hop their inspiration can be
heard in everything from the mingoes
flow to Aesop mom's beats some artists
even go so far as copying the group
chants rapper Travis Scott was sued by
DJ Paul for using the tear the club up
chant in this 2018 song no bystanders
now ray and I are gonna create a three 6
mafia inspired track the simplicity is
the main thing notice all this stuff
going on in the track and it still
sounds simple maybe is because of the
poly tonality you have to rub the
different chords have to rub let's see
[Music]
real quick nari what is that from what
is what are you doing you just made that
up just now yeah ok can you remember
that came to keep that I lost it already
know one of the characteristics of
chronic music is the distorted 808 like
I'm saying you hear that in the trunk
rattling down the street like you know
the 808 other ones is like full attack
really pungent and usually I want to go
for like a more clean more round home
warm 808 I stay away from the distorted
joints but this is gonna be cool I think
it'll be fun for us to put this together
because we can just be uninhibited check
out our other series American from
scratch
another PBS Digital Studios show that
asks what would America be like if it
was founded today it tacos big questions
what if there are no States should we
lower the voting age should we colonize
Mars it's like the best civics class
ever
subscribe to America from scratch using
the link in the description below we put
the instrumental of our original song on
soundcloud so go download it and rap on
it
[Music]